hi
what's up i'm heather jackson and i'm
emilia
uh i'm chris i'm ashlyn's father are you
open
with each other yeah we talk about
everything pretty much right
i think so you know i'm in college now i
don't tell you everything that i'm doing
there yeah yeah
i don't know that i want to today you're
going to be swapping phones
what are you curious about i want to see
if her and my sister talk [ __ ] about me
i already know they probably do so i
definitely want to go through that
whoa here's what i'm saying there's no
way your mom has a haircut like that and
you're sexually conservative
leopard print hair like that big-ass
glasses come on now
are any of you nervous yeah i definitely
uh did not know what i was getting into
until about a day and a half ago not
normally something that i would agree to
a lot of fathers operate under the uh
see no evil do no evil kind of thing
right like yeah as long as i don't hear
it or see it i don't want to know about
it
they don't even want to think about it
so pretty much
you have your mother's phone where are
you going to begin is it
okay if i were to order myself something
on amazon
[Music]
first thing she does is spend her mama
money god damn girl
goddamn it's absolutely not okay you
have free reign
yo the only thing she's thinking about
is
add revenue let's go yeah oh
my god place order oh
my god okay an immigrant would never
think of doing that to their parent
nope because if i spend your money now
i'm gonna pay later
i'm paying somehow definitely
i'm 38 years ago my mother
a lot of stuff wow he's never cleared
out
any of these i've been scrolling this
whole time i'll go to the text
i'm scared i'm going through the
pictures and videos he has with
my stepmom
[Laughter]
it was her tit
[Music]
[Laughter]
look for the porn oh god well there
there goes one right there
yes
[Laughter]
i'm thinking about that jay-z saw old
[ __ ] young [ __ ] fresh [ __ ] cool [ __ ]
doesn't go to incognito mode what is
that a week with me
or ps5 what do you know this old man's
version of dirty man memes you know what
i'm saying
i'm simple like that
that's the uncle that's my uncle right
there i'll give a [ __ ] what'd you say
i don't know i don't even know the man's
name i don't really give a [ __ ]
that's my uncle right there let's go i'm
simple like that
you know it's fun chap okay let's see
about 50 bucks real quick
what i don't think you can get in there
so yeah i'm on it now
you gonna take some money for me bro oh
wow
i just saved myself 50 bucks you're
about to whoop his head that's what i
said
he did that he tried that he's about to
open his head yeah yeah i cash out you
50 dollars you will catch that mean 100
watch
all right now go to the search history
oh
oh how do you do that so you know safari
like when
nancy i'm not good at all that where's
the part yet um should be at the bottom
google oh gosh
hey this would not be an old if he knew
how to use phones effortlessly
exactly seriously she took a picture
of a hickey that she gave her girlfriend
apparently they're in middle school or
something
you don't need to ask your sister what
your mama thinks of you i mean she's
saying it right now the pettiness is
the pettiness is nice anyways well i see
some pornhub stuff down there
black goddess click on it what's he been
watching
bro that's real that's reals porn
that's not absolutely that's not you
can't show that can i get out of there
can i get out of there yo i would pay so
much money to watch old people have to
exit
porn links or viruses just be like
are you just watching close their laptop
being overwhelmed that's funny let's see
something's going on with him with
olivia
does kyle have a crush on this girl
they've been hanging out a little bit so
no there's nothing going on
that's a [ __ ] who definitely has a
crush on her still
and doesn't want to ruin his chances by
this coming up you know i'm saying don't
you
don't play me accidentally i'm gonna say
you want me to come get you later
oh god he's been really thinking about
you oh
no that's that fifty dollar the year
that's that's the two dollar cash app
right there
you paid yeah i i paid you it's for
that's what i'm about to you i'm about
to get it back
now you're gonna go to your sisters oh
yeah that's
not gonna be good because i know they
talk [ __ ] about me
oh jesus i'm in oh god i'm gonna say
amelia is pregnant oh my god
okay so she said bye who oh my god my
sister actually believed that i'm
pregnant
hey listen i knew you were writing a
fake message and i believed that you
were pregnant
oh no that's not olivia
olivia says yeah sure i think we need to
help kyle out and you need to send one
more thing
i said i want to talk about me and you
you've been heavy on my mind
yo bring it back you're about to do that
i said i want to talk about me and you
you've been heavy on my mind
the sound's still on
[Laughter]
okay what's up ooh i'm even going harder
uh-oh kyle you okay i'm fine
you're not you're not i'm totally fine
kyle do you have feelings for this girl
um
you know what this makes me think of
remember that that cold at black moment
do you have a crush on this girl and
then kodak goes
i hope so yeah yeah you never see that
yeah you think you could be monogamous
though yeah
do you know what monogamous mean kodak
no i know exactly
that means that can you be faithful to
one one woman all the way
yeah i could listen the other night i
fell asleep on the phone with a girl
i ain't do that since like middle school
that's your girl
what was you saying to her we were just
chopping it up like something
for the first night ever you talked to
only one girl yeah
i
that's hope same energy that i've got
for this guy
here we go let's find out kyle do you
have feelings for this girl
um no
i think i may be falling for you we
should hook up oh no no he didn't have
dirty with that last text
he said i i think i think i might be
falling for you we should hook up
oh he did him dirty but at least he
should not cost 50 bucks
hey i don't care if you shoot like this
or you shoot like this at least you
gotta shoot
dang it i feel this you know what he's
thinking right now he's like
that fifty dollars was it worth it hey
what's she doing here
oh my god no
[Applause]
who does that you have children you're a
mother
oh my god all right put the phone down
so we're going to bring your daughter in
and we're gonna have youtube chat
how was that perfectly fine
did you learn anything um that my sister
really thinks that i would just
get pregnant like that don't you already
have a kid
my sister really thinks that i would do
something
that i already did i already did
it's like you murdering someone and then
someone's like did you murder another
person you're like
you think that i would kill someone
how'd you feel about me taking that 50
bucks i'm getting that back that's no
question you can't get it back though
you don't know
i'll get it back it's unbackable
i can just contact olivia sub now [ __ ]
there goes the answer you guys are
waiting for what you say
says i think no what i think no
i think that was what you're saying yeah
he said i think i may be falling for you
we should hook up
i think no
oh well
oh well now you're going to have to
explain that to her that cost you 50
bucks
that was perfect good for him that was
good that was awesome i really enjoyed
that one
what you guys think in the comments
below you guys enjoyed today's video do
you guys have a good laugh if so let us
know
which part you enjoyed the most
and with that i'm going to end deuces
oh by the way we got a patreon where we
put out exclusive videos
go there get exclusive album preach
[Music]
videos
foreign
[Music]
oh